das macht der mond im jahr 2016 ebola
ist vorbei und fällt hinein rakete
sicher zurück das sind drei der fünf
themen in den blick zum 250
beeindruckende videoaufnahmen eines
aktes dux also eines riesen khammas am
24 dezember besuchte ein exemplar den
hafen von pro jahr in japan das rund
vier meter lange tier folgte einem
fischerboot in die seichten gewässer
diese tiere sind bisher noch nicht
vollständig erforscht es gab immer
wieder sichtungen solche exemplare
aber früher wurden diese oft als mythos
abgetan erst 2004 wurde das erste mal
ein architekt ucs fotografiert und jetzt
gelang es einem taucher so ein tier in
seichtem gewässer zu filmen seichte
gewässer gehören eigentlich nicht zu
ihrem lebensraum die riesen kalmare
bewohnen die tiefsee rund 300 bis 1000
meter unter der wasseroberfläche
die herkunftsgebiete liegen teilweise
weit auseinander und dennoch konnten
experten bei dna proben von den kann man
kaum unterschiede feststellen
1 k der aus amerika kommt unterscheidet
sich demnach unwesentlich von einem der
aus japan kommt das exemplar aus dem
japanischen hafen war mit seinen vier
metern übrigens noch eines der kleineren
ausgaben die tiere sollen eine
gesamtlänge von bis zu über 18 metern
erreichen können sind die probleme um
ebola endlich gelöst die
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu hat die
ebola epidemie für beendet erklärt dabei
sah das kürzlich noch anders aus noch
vor rund einem monat sagte
gesundheitsministerin liberias wer
niesen
zitat der kampf gegen ebola ist nicht
vorbei aber wir dürfen die hoffnung
nicht verlieren zitat ende
damals erkrankte ein zehnjähriger junge
sein vater und einer seiner geschwister
an ebola seine mutter im dezember 2013
ausgebrochen ist starben geschätzt
11.300 menschen an den folgen der
infektion
rund 28.600 menschen wurden infiziert
die dunkelziffer sei allerdings viel
höher liegen in guinea dem land in dem
das virus zuerst ausbrach konnte jetzt
aber ein großer erfolg errungen werden
es sind 42 tage vergangen ohne dass es
zu neuinfektionen
ist erreicht an land dieses ziel gilt es
als ebola frei auch wenn die whu die
ebola epidemie als beendet erklärt sei
es dennoch wichtig auch im jahr 2016
weiterhin aufmerksam zu bleiben
ein jahr nach dem missglückten versuch
des privaten raumfahrtunternehmen spacex
eine ihrer felken ein raketen nach einem
einsatz wieder zu landen können wir
jetzt von einer erfolgreichen landung
einer falcon 9 berichten anders als
andere raumfahrtunternehmen möchte
spacex seine raketen in zukunft mehrfach
verwenden können
die mission kosten für so eine 26
missionen die belaufen sich auf rund 50
millionen euro während der treibstoff
gerade einmal 175000 euro kostet vielen
mass gründer von spacex vergleicht die
herkömmliche art mit raketen zu
verfahren mit einer brandneuen boeing
747 die man nach nur einem flug
verschrottet die wiederverwendung von
raketen könnte eine neue ära der
raumfahrt einläuten in der die flüge ins
all um einiges billiger werden
das raumfahrtunternehmen spacex könnte
so eine gewaltige menge an geld sparen
in einem tweet vielen maske die rakete
mit den worten welcome back baby zurück
auf der erde willkommen wie die landung
ausgesehen hat das könnte jetzt sehen
der korb
musikalische familien auf
als jetzt
keine zigaretten kein alkohol und eine
gesunde ernährung alles regeln für
schwangere frauen aber was ist
eigentlich mit den männern müssen männer
nicht auch dazu beitragen dass das kind
gesund zur welt kommt was genau männer
dafür tun können um gesunde kinder zu
zeugen haben wissenschaftler jetzt im
fachmagazin science erklärt auch für
männer gelten nämlich regeln dienen sie
einhalten sollten zum beispiel bei der
ernährung ein team der university of
nevada in reno ernährte männliche mäuse
ein halbes jahr lang mit 60 prozent
fetthaltiger nahrung nur der von den
menschen daraufhin gezeugte nachwuchs
zeigte schon in der siebten woche erste
auswirkungen der väterlichen ernährung
die jungtiere litten teilweise unterhose
intoleranz und oder einer
insulinresistenz damit hatten die tiere
die grundbedingungen für eine diabetes
erkrankung so gut wie erfüllt die
ungesunde ernährung führt zur
veränderung in der rna im sperma diese
ribonukleinsäure speichert unter anderem
die information über das essverhalten
des vaters
das wird dann weiter fahrt das ist
allerdings keine mutationen sondern
epigenetik die gehen informationen
werden dadurch beeinflusst durch die
ernährung kann der mann also
informationen an den nachwuchs
weitergeben
das macht der mond im jahr 2016 die nasa
zeigt uns diese aufnahmen wie sich der
mond im ersten quartal 2016 verhalten
wird hier ist das video dazu zu sehen
ist der zeitraum januar bis ende märz
beeindruckende aufnahmen ja wenn ihr das
ganze video sehen wollt dann schaut mal
in der video beschreibung nach dort
verlegen wir es euch da wir jetzt ganz
am anfang des jahres sind da würde mich
mal interessieren was hat das jahr 2015
für euch besonders gemacht also was
waren die spannenden entwicklungen der
wissenschaft und was erwartet für ihr
von 2016
ich bin zum beispiel gespannt mal auf
und dem beweis des holografischen
universums er noch aussteht ja schreibt
und rein in die kommentare vergessen
nicht clixoom zu abonnieren bisher
kostenlos las einen daumen hoch daumen
hoch und schaut das nächste video
ansonsten bleibt dran